first of all congratulations on the
movie I really really loved it
um and I have to start by asking what I
think is the most important question
which is what is your favorite beanie
baby
you know I I actually didn't collect
beanie babies
um but I think uh spot would be one for
sure
um because I just like I like puppies
and dogs and you know that's probably
one of my like favorite if I had to pick
one no I love that that's a great choice
um I love how many sort of feminist
period pieces you've been doing lately
call Jane was one of my favorite movies
of last year obviously Mrs America I'm
curious what it is about these kind of
projects that's really like drawing you
to them right now oh you know I just
love these characters I mean I think
what's great about these is
um these story lines for me is that are
ultimately about women with a sense of
agency that are sort of doing things for
themselves that are not reliant on you
know on the male characters I think one
of the themes of this movie is that
Robbie felt like a supporting character
and Ty's story and that's a theme that
you see like literally the creators made
this movie to
um investigate that idea right and I
definitely feel like somebody I mean I'm
a female actress who's come up through
Hollywood like I've definitely had to
play a lot of supporting roles you know
um and I just feel like this is about
women who broke out of that and and
created their own lane Their Own Story
took control of their life you know
despite
um this huge personality that Ty Warner
is and represents and still is to this
day you know that they were able to
carve out their own sense of self
um apart from him I thought was really
fascinating yeah and you mentioned the
directors and I always really enjoy the
films that you direct obviously this is
their debut feature but I'm curious if
there's anything in their approach that
you were like I want to do that next
time that I step behind camera you know
that's so interesting you asked that
because they um Damien is obviously very
musical
um and he loves to use Rhythm as a
directing tool and I actually did learn
a little bit about that I was like oh
that's an interesting approach might be
something that I try someday yeah I love
that they're just so many fun scenes in
this movie too I feel like the drunk
pool scene is gonna stick with me the
kind of conspiring with rose is gonna
stick with me I'm curious what was the
most fun to shoot for you the pool scene
for sure I I bring it up all the time I
we shot it actually pretty early in the
schedule
um and so
um you know Zach and I we had not really
met until we started working on this
movie together and
um so we were two characters and two
actors who were actually having to
create this connection with each other
and I I hate playing drunk people it's
always so scary as an actor you never
want to overdo it it's always hard and
and more than anything I just wanted to
be very Carefree in the pool and working
with Zach and Damien and Kristen allowed
me to just do that and just play I re
we've had a great sense of playfulness
that night
um and I had one idea that they took to
heart which is that I really wanted him
to be above me in the pool and I was
like how are we gonna figure this out is
he gonna be on a you know what are we
gonna do and they came up with that
floating chair for him to be on which I
loved you know because that's their
power Dynamic begins in that pool which
is he is inviting her into something
it's you know it's Himalayan cats is his
idea and she doesn't recognize that
she's not an equal in that relationship
and I I loved exploring that I in the
physicality of it too yeah I really
really love that detail um I have to rap
but it was so great getting to speak to
you about this and I'm so excited for
everyone to see it thank you